Does he still have the asset?
yes our source confirmed it
and we will be ready
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new video for the mandalorian season 2
dark troopers that they just revealed at the end
of last week's episode so if you're brand new to
the channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get everything we'll do
a new giveaway for disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you think they're going to do
with these troopers careful for spoilers from
everything that's happened on the mandalorians
so far we'll just do top 10 wtf and easter eggs
as we go along starting with number 10 moff gideon
reveals that he's planted a new tracking device on
the razor crest so that he can track mando in the
child or baby yoda whatever you want to call him
and snatch him back so that he can complete more
testing to perfect his experiments in creating
the new dark troopers that we learned from
dr purging's recording earlier in the episode
he says they need more baby ota's blood in order
to continue the experiments because the last time
they had him he was so small physically that he
wasn't able to drain very much without killing him
he also referenced using test subjects with high m
count m standing for midichlorians because yoda's
species has an extremely high midichlorian count
naturally all members of his race not just yoda
himself and yes the child is not yoda himself
this is taking place after return of the jedi
yoda has already died this is just another child
of yoda's race that's why we call him a baby yoda
make all the prequels midichlorians jokes
you want they tried to reference it in a
very roundabout way but it was pretty obvious
what they were trying to talk about the whole
idea though is that the higher the midichlorian
count a being has the more innate connection to
the force that they have potentially making them
much more powerful but as we've seen with baby
yoda just because he's extremely connected to the
force and powerful there are other more powerful
beings that are more trained it's just because of
his physiology he has a much higher theoretical
potential for power it was the same thing with
anakin skywalker midichlorian count off the charts
if he hadn't been maimed by obi-wan and revenge of
the sith post all the high ground memes he could
have potentially become even more powerful than
master yoda so it's just easy to understand why
maf gideon wants to use the force as a concept
as part of his experiments in creating these
new dark troopers it also seems like they're
incorporating some aspects of the purge troopers
from the force unleashed video game two with how
darth vader repurposed converted clone troopers
the purge troopers were different from the dark
troopers though completely different concepts
from different parts of the star wars legends
number nine dark troopers are a huge easter
egg for the star wars dark forces video game
from back in the day total classic most of you
probably either played it or some version of it or
at least knew about it or seen videos about it the
main character that game was kyle katarn it took
place during the timeline of the original trilogy
no idea if this means that we'll actually get
kyle katarn showing up on the series but he's fair
game they can do anything they want they can
pluck anything out of legends cannon and make it
official new cannon again they did the exact same
thing with grand admiral thrawn during star wars
rebels back when disney bought lucasfilm in star
wars they said that the legends stuff the novels
the video games everything from before besides
the movies in the clone wars series was no longer
canon and the new official canon would just be the
new disney produced star wars material tv shows
books new video games in addition to the classic
movies in the clone wars series you get the idea
but what happened was is dave filoni who ran star
wars rebels the clone wars would cleverly pluck
little aspects and characters and things from
legends and put them in the clone wars and rebels
making them new canon again so grand admiral
thrawn was just the biggest example of that now
it seems like they're doing the same thing with
the dark troopers from the dark forces video game
it was so long ago i can't remember if i played
the dos version of that or if i played the windows
version because the transition to the windows
operating system is kind of fuzzy in my mind i
was so young at the time so you can say now that
at least some of the aspects of the dark forces
video game is canon again but maybe if they're
doing this we'll finally get them canonizing
some more shadows of the empire stuff and dash
rendar number eight the actual dark troopers on
the show seem like they're mostly inspired by the
design of the phase 2 dark troopers which are just
evolved versions of the original project they also
had even more upgraded phase 3 dark troopers in
the game that started to look more like star wars
version of cylons but that's basically what the
dark troopers are they're kind of like cylons
cybernetic hybrid stormtroopers they're made
from the bodies of former clones upgraded with
cybernetic technology like darth vader's sith tech
armor suit it's all just designed to make them
much more powerful and way harder to kill than
normal stormtroopers remember all the jokes from
the past few seasons on the mandalorian and how
terrible stormtroopers aim is and how incompetent
they are well dark troopers are the answer to that
and i know there were a lot of questions about
the failed clones and the tanks and snoke from the
rise of skywalker with the snoke clones and the
sith cloning tanks and emperor palpatine's clones
don't worry i'll address that in a second too
that's kind of a separate thing but originally the
whole concept for the dark trooper project within
the empire was the brainchild of someone called
general rom mock who just really loved the idea
of close combat with the rebellion and thought
that was a better route to go than super weapons
like the first death star so he started the dark
trooper project on a customized capital ship
where he produced them and experimented on them
the same way it seems like moff gideon is doing
with his capital ship the phase two ones that
looks like moff gideon has in the original video
game were rolled out right after the destruction
of the first death star just to give you an idea
for where they fit in the timeline number seven
the reason why they're adding baby yoda's blood
his high midichlorian dna to the experiments is
because they're trying to upgrade them even more
like why not take all the best attributes from
around the galaxy and combine them to create
invincible stormtroopers that's the whole
point of the dark trooper project moff gideon
is just taking it a step further and because
they're a combination of human body parts with
special exoskeletons and cybernetic enhancements
they're much easier to control than traditional
clone troopers or regular stormtroopers
so that's why it's important that they have all
this cloning technology number six the whole scene
with the failed experiments in the cloning tanks
is just meant to be a reference to the failed
snoke clones from the rights of skywalker and just
generally a reference to the clones from attack of
clones on kamino because dr purging wears the
kamino cloning insignia on his imperial uniform
meaning that they're trying to use cloning to try
and perfect subjects to add to the dark trooper
armor exoskeletons that's why they're making
all these reveals in the same episode so that
you know why they wanted baby yoda in the first
place while they're experimenting with new clones
and force sensitive test subjects and combining a
lot of different concepts and easter eggs from the
movies the tv shows and the video games to get to
their dark trooper project some off gideon is kind
of like a new version of darth vader combined with
this general raw mock from the dark forces video
game i'm sure they're going to canonize a whole
bunch of other deep cuts from the legends stuff so
they'll just be adding to this season to season
it'll just keep getting deeper and deeper and
deeper as we go along i just love the idea that
it seems like jon favreau and dave filoni are such
big fans of the classic video games like we even
had a knights of the old republic easter egg with
the crate dragon in episode one that was written
by john favreau so you know he was a fan of that
video game number five the other thing that he
says at the end of the episode is that he'll be
ready for them talking about both mando bogatan
and the night owls with the other divisions of
mandalorians she potentially commands because now
he knows that she got away with the ship and the
weapons at the end of episode three will be ready
for them what he means is is that they're going
to roll the dark troopers out to fight them in
a sort of reverse twist on the big mandalorian
assault from season one episode three when all the
mandos came to save him and baby yoda they were so
powerful they steamrolled all the bounty hunters
in the streets it was a badass scene now just
imagine the dark version of that where moff gideon
kind of steamrolls all the mandalorians in mando
with the dark troopers in number four i've also
seen a lot of comments and questions about whether
or not the dark trooper's armor is made of bescar
because back in season one they revealed that the
empire stole all the best scar from mandalore when
they took the planet in the great purge and even
though they treated mando's bounty like it was
an enormous amount worth a priceless sum of money
everyone like the aqualish the mando encounters
has been trying to steal the best scar from him
because it's worth so much money that amount of
best gar represented a tiny fraction of the amount
that the empire had so it would make sense that
maf gideon has a ton of it and could use it to
further upgrade the dark troopers so now it makes
more sense that scene from episode 3 where mando
uses himself as a human shield for boca tan and
the night owls and just runs the gauntlet to take
out the stormtroopers soaking all their blaster
fire and yes it does look like it hurts them
but the best scar is so strong that the blaster
shots just bounce off of him like it's no big deal
they probably had that scene to let you know how
strong besgar is so they can do a big reverse
twist when the dark troopers roll out and the same
thing happens with them so heading into the last
couple of episodes they're just trying to hype
up the dark troopers as being nearly invincible
number three this is where the jedi and former
jedi characters like ahsoka can help out
vesgar armor is naturally resistant to lightsabers
that's the whole reason the mandalorians created
in the first place after the early battles in
the jedi mandalorian wars thousands of years ago
but when normal troops even bad ass ones like
mandalorians aren't enough to take down moff
gideon's dark troopers you need even more powerful
people to help out and more powerful techniques
that's why you would go to the jedi and anybody
that could swing a lightsaber whether or not
their fallen jedi former jedi or anywhere in
between i don't know how many episodes ahsoka
is supposed to be in this season but even if she
herself doesn't get into any lightsaber fights
she can still give mando the advice he needs
to fight moff gideon's forces in number two
really important you also have to remember mando
bocatan the other mandalorians don't know anything
about the dark trooper project so moff gideon
still has the element of surprise and because
regular stormtroopers are so squishy against them
they're heading into a fight against him expecting
to steamroll his forces which is where we get to
our empire strikes back style ending in a new hope
the rebellion humiliated the empire by destroying
the death star but when we get to empire strikes
back darth vader and their forces proved that they
weren't all incompetent they were a real threat
they captured han solo frozen in carbonite he
cut luke's hand off and they almost destroyed the
rebel fleet so mando humiliated moff gideon at the
end of season one now it's maf gideon's turn to
strike back at the end of season two and as for
the snoke rise of skywalker emperor palpatine
cloning experiments connection yes the theme
music during this scene does sound similar to the
john williams snoke theme music and obviously they
played it again during rise of skywalker when they
passed by the snoke tank of clones when emperor
palpatine said he made snoke he literally meant
he made snoke like he was a cloning experiment
with force sensitive dna and midichlorians
but i think that's where the connection ends
just sort of a surface level connection they're
trying to make and cloning force sensitives maf
gideon for his dark trooper project separately
from what they were doing with snoke and emperor
palpatine but number one early prediction for the
mandalorian season two ending empire strikes back
style maf gideon uses the dark troopers to trash
Bo Katan the mandalorians and mando himself and
also before the dark trooper reveal i'd expected
boba fett to play a role in that that's still
possible because mando has boba fett's armor
and the way they ended season 2 episode 1 implied
that boba fett was now tracking him waiting for
an opportunity to take back his armor and possibly
collect the huge bounty on the child but there's a
whole bunch of unresolved hanging plot threads
to tie up before the end of the season between
the dark troopers boba fett and baby yoda so
everyone post all your theories in the comments
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 5 video
is going to post on friday it does seem like
that's going to be the ahsoka episode so i'll do
some more bonus videos for her this week as well
congratulations to the giveaway winner from
my last big star wars video kenneth disinger
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your contact details everyone click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 4
video and click here for my mandalorian season 2
ahsoka tano video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!